ahora ya sabemos las derivadas de senos
y cosenos sabemos que la derivada con
respecto a x del seno de x es igual al
coste no de x y también sabemos que la
derivada con respecto a x del coseno de
x es igual al menos seno de x y lo que
queremos hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar las derivadas de las otras
funciones trigonométricas básicas así
que en particular vamos a averiguar
primero la derivada con respecto a x la
derivada con respecto a x de y bueno qué
te parece si empezamos con la tangente
de x
gente de equis y bueno para sacar esta
derivada lo que vamos a hacer es
expresar la tangente como la división de
seno entre coseno esto es lo mismo que
la derivada con respecto a x de d el
seno de x déjame ponerlo con otro color
dividido a su vez entre el seno de
y bueno esa es la definición de la
tangente así que vamos a calcular esta
derivada y como la tangente se puede
expresar como el cociente de dos
funciones aquí podemos aplicar la regla
del cociente para evaluar esta derivada
la regla de cociente nos dicen que esto
va a ser igual am y primero me fijo en
la derivada del de arriba la derivada de
ese no es el coseno de x así que me
quedaría coseno de x ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la función que tenemos
abajo que es cosa de x entonces a esto
lo voy a multiplicar por 12 no de x ok
ya esto hay que quitarle bueno la
función que tenemos arriba la función
que tenemos arriba es seno de x
que multiplica a la derivada de la
función que tenemos abajo pero la
derivada del coseno dx es el menos de
equis así que voy a poner aquí el seno
de x el seno de x y este signo menos lo
voy a poner aquí de tal manera que va a
cancelar este y ahora vamos a dividir
todo esto vamos a dividir todo esto
entre la función que tenemos abajo
elevada al cuadrado es decir coseno
cuadrado de x ok si observas acá arriba
vamos a tener coseno de x por coseno de
x bueno eso es lo mismo que poseen o
cuadrados de x más y por otra parte
tengo seno de x por seno de x lo cual es
seno cuadrado de x y ahora qué es esto
que es esto que tenemos aquí si
recuerdas sabemos la identidad
pitagórica y eso en realidad salió de la
definición del círculo unitario así que
todo esto va a ser exactamente igual que
uno para cualquier equis entonces todo
esto va a ser igual a 1 entre el coche
no cuadrado de x 1 / coseno cuadrado de
x lo podemos escribir también como la
secante cuadrada de x recuerda que uno
entre coseno es la secante entonces si
lo elevamos al cuadrado me queda esta
expresión que tengo aquí así que ya está
esto fue bastante sencillo ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo para el recíproco de la
función tangente es decir me voy a tomar
la derivada la derivada con respecto a x
pero ahora de la función o tangente de x
con tangente de equis y bueno esto va a
ser igual y otra vez pensemos en la cota
en gente como la división del coseno de
x entre el seno de x así que esto es lo
mismo que la derivada con respecto a x
y bueno de él coseno de x lo voy a poner
con este color del coste de x esto que a
su vez está dividido esto a su vez está
dividido entre el seno de x entre el
seno de
y ahora me quiero tomar la derivada de
esto que tenemos aquí bueno pues esto va
a ser igual y una vez más podemos usar
la regla del cociente entonces esto va a
ser igual a la derivada de la función
que tenemos arriba la derivada del
coseno recuerda que es el menos seno
entonces menos el seno de x muy bien
menos el seno de x por la función que
tenemos abajo que es el seno de x por el
seno por el seno de x ya esto hay que
quitarle la función que tenemos arriba
que es el coce no de x
y a esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de la función que tenemos abajo
la derivada del seno es el coseno de x
por el coseno de x y bueno a todo esto
hay que dividirlo a todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre la función que tenemos
abajo elevada al cuadrado
entonces me va a quedar el seno cuadrado
de x
entonces ahora que podemos simplificar
bueno veamos estos dos son lo mismo que
el seno cuadrado de x el seno cuadrado
de x y estos dos son lo mismo que el
coce no
cuadrado de x así que me quedan menos el
seno cuadrado de x menos el coste no
cuadrado de x pero podemos factor y ser
de aquí un signo negativo esto es lo
mismo que menos
no cuadrado de x
más el coche no cuadrado de x ok y si
observas todo esto de aquí va a ser lo
mismo que uno estoy recordando la
identidad pitagórica entonces me queda
esto es lo mismo que menos uno entre el
seno cuadrado de x el seno cuadrado de x
muy bien y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que uno entre el seno de x es la co
secante de x
entonces me quedarían menos la co
secante cuadrada de x
y ahí lo tienes